les collectivités ont elles pour vous
les moyens et les capacités de mettre en
oeuvre tous les plans de confinement de
déconfinement ça fait partie des
questions qui sont sur la table mais les
collectivités en attendant sont d'ores
et déjà engagés est donc prête à jouer
cette carte à la fois du partenariat et
de la confiance sans lequel le
déconfinement ne peut pas être une
réussite est aujourd'hui évidemment un
certain nombre de questions restent en
suspens sur poserait une tout à l'heure
à la séance des questions sur le risque
d'engager sa responsabilité pénale quand
on est chef d'entreprise que ce soit les
entreprises privées les pme les
associations mais aussi des entreprises
publiques à commencer par les mairies
mais d'autres questions sont également
sur la table et je pense qu'il ya un
problème de méthode maintenant entre
l'état et les collectivités
oui tout à fait d'ailleurs les maires
notamment sont en première ligne pour la
réouverture des écoles
c'est une logistique très complexe a dit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui gérard collomb il
a dit que c'était très difficile à
organiser
avec un coût considérable c'est le grand
flou pour vous en fait qu'il y ait
l'acceptation d'une géométrie variable
territoire par territoire situation par
situation voire commune par commune
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
ainsi c'était je ne veux voir qu'une
seule tête on serait plutôt inquiet mais
évidemment la contrepartie de sa sait
que c'est compliqué et que toute une
série de questions sont aujourd'hui sur
la table la question juridique et lui
risque pénal est une question parmi
d'autres oiseaux
on avait tout à l'heure avec les élus
parlementaires de mon département la
juste à l'instant une réunion avec le
préfet avec en présence de l'inspectrice
d'académie
cette question est celle qui est venue
le plus sur la table
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
unis n'est pas forcément les moyens les
moyens de photos par exemple les moyens
sont aujourd'hui variable selon les
communes et on attend que d'ici le 11
mai et au delà les moyens monte en
puissance moi je ne suis pas pessimiste
par principe je pense que par moment il
faut se faire un peu confiance tout en
étant vigilant et puis je dirais
derrière les moyens il ya aussi on l'a
vu sur les masques etc
la question de la bonne organisation de
qui fait quoi et de la méthode et nous
faisons et nous ferons dans les
prochains jours
la très vite au niveau de la délégation
aux collectivités territoriales et en
accord avec le président du sénat une
proposition que nous avons d'ailleurs
validé avec les grandes associations
d'élus maires de france départements
régions que nous avons donné la semaine
dernière d'un protocole d'accord 1
avec ces associations soutenues par le
sénat en dialogue avec les pouvoirs
publics sur les 12 grandes priorités je
vous en donne juste une pour avoir un
exemple c'est l'idée dans cinq
départements qui est autour du préfet
une task force un de manière à ce qu'ils
aient une autorité unique ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas au niveau de l'état
mais aussi une méthode affiné au niveau
du lien avec les territoires avec les
différentes administrations le sanitaire
les sapeurs-pompiers le monde économique
parce que au fond tout va redémarrer
ensemble et il faut donc que de ce point
de vue là nous ayons une organisation et
une autorité claire une proposition donc
méthodologique vous aurez ensuite
transmettre transmettre au gouvernement
bien entendu bien entendu avec l'espoir
que ce sera une contribution à ce
qu'attendait le premier ministre
c'est-à-dire à des confinement qui se
passe en bon ordre et en tenant compte
de la diversité des situations et jean
marie bockel un mot enfin sur la
situation est bien du grand est une zone
bien sûr qui a été particulièrement
touché un bien sûr par l'épidémie de
coronavirus qui va rester zone rouge
certainement pendant très longtemps
quels sont pour vous une allée des
grands pointe de difficultés en
particulier sur la région mais s'ils
voulaient d'abord une région elle est
diverse le grotesque
évidemment la situation n'est pas la
même dans certains départements
euro que dans le bas-rhin et plus encore
dans le haut rhin
donc il faut savoir au niveau de la
région jean retenir le fait d'ailleurs
très bien de président de région tenir
compte de cette diversité
les présidents de département joue à
gilles klein carte présente chez moi
sont également très engagé et les choses
sont bien coordonnées mais là nous avons
peut-être plus que dans les pyrénées
atlantiques par exemple un département
que j'aime beaucoup
une urgence sanitaire qui malgré la
décrue reste très prégnante chez nous
évidemment les précautions à prendre
pour qu'il n'y ait pas une deuxième
vague 1 ça reste quand même une priorité
en fait l'état d'esprit chez nous s'est
il faut pas se reposer trop vite non pas
sur les lauriers mais sur les réussites
qui a déjà eu grâce notamment aux
soignants il ya toutes les mobilisations
restons vigilants pas un mot juste pour
terminer est ce que il ya au vu de tout
cela vous pensez que vous allez voter le
plan de déconfinement la semaine
prochaine vous savez au groupe centriste
nous avons une grande liberté
personnellement j'ai plutôt un état
d'esprit constructif
donc j'attends de voir pour prendre la
décision